you're you're a Muslim I am when did you
become Muslim not 17. what were the
circumstances oh that was like believing
in God and stuff
I'm not like you know I mean I should
preface this by saying it's not like I'm
good at it
when I was 17 I was living in Washington
and there was a pizza shop across from
my house
and it was like all these Muslim dudes
they're working there and I used to go
in there and crack jokes and I also I
was a naturally curious guy and I would
ask him questions about his religion it
was and the guy was so passionate about
it it was very compelling I like the
perspective of it and I think these
things are for my decision that I wanted
to have a meaningful life a spiritual
life I'm reading about you being Muslim
and they reference something that I was
fascinated by The Well of zamzam there's
a well called Sam says yeah Saudi Arabia
and the myth goes that a family walking
through this desert dying of thirst
and this endless well presents itself
you and I can go see it right so I could
go see it you probably have to make some
phone calls have you have you been there
I have it's only welcome to Muslims it's
not a tourist location no nor should it
be the man is the prophet Abraham and
his wife the word zamzam the you guys
speak Arabic literally means stop stop
because when there was commanded that
this well would appear the water gushed
forth so much that the wine screams you
stop Stoppers because it was so
overwhelming and they say that it's an
inexhaustible well the thing that
comforts me about it is the idea that
all of this is from a singular source
that this source is ultimately kind and
even though we may not understand the
intentions of this Source they were all
connected and bounded by it you know
like it's not as it's been presented in
the public space it's such a narrow and
and dismissive view of
of a religious belief it's a it's a
beautiful religion like a beautiful
religion and the ideas in that religion
are reflected in all the major abrahamic
faiths you'll see these ideas and
Christianity or Judaism you know so even
that picture of thousands of Muslims
congregated in that square wherever they
just were I can honestly tell you that I
felt differently seeing that just now
than I have and then you have when
you've seen that kind of stuff in the
past before born I've seen something and
it was perfectly peaceful and if you
showed me that exact scene a year ago or
just weeks ago before we really started
digging into and trying to understand
this this other religion I would have
had a a different physical and emotional
reaction to it it would have caused me I
I felt there was something off and weird
and foreign and seeing that just now I
saw like go back to that for a second
that that that scene like in the the
ideas that just looks utterly calm and
peaceful and it doesn't look weird where
I would have thought like is this the
endless well uh I no idea no idea wait
isn't there one there's like something
that they all pray to right like
everyone when they pray they like they
go in One Direction aiming at this one
thing on earth I don't know what it is
but I'm pretty sure that's I don't know
if it has anything to do with the well
but anyway I I just really noticed some
a change in myself that's funny yeah I
can't even really articulate it well but
I think it's I'm really freaking happy
about it to be able to look at an entire
population 25 of the Earth's population
through a Kinder eye is the kind of
personal growth that I personally want
for myself it was cool all right carrot
keep going I'm sorry to interrupt with
that no that's good that you pointed
that out sometimes you notice stuff like
that yeah I felt it Christianity or
Judaism you know but the idea is that
this place does mean something it's a
place where you come to learn where you
come to know you get here knowing
nothing you get a head full of [ __ ] and
then you go on
when the current President says uh you
know what we're going to look into
keeping Muslims out of this country how
does that make you feel when that
happens you don't expect necessarily
that much empathy or Compassion or
cultural astuteness from a guy like that
what you said about is that the chair
doesn't have more Humanity in it did he
say that or did he know he was he was
concerned my understanding okay and
again let's dig deeper because we talk
all the time about what the news tells
us so everything I ever said he wasn't
talking about them Trump wasn't talking
about the Muslim religion what I saw he
was talking about countries where there
were political danger for this country
and keeping those people out it wasn't
about the religion and they happened to
be predominantly Muslim countries so
that's a big difference
that government sucks or there are
terrorist organizations there that want
to kill us that are running those
countries and let's keep them out that's
a big [ __ ] difference from that and I
hate Muslims so I think that was a media
twisting frankly but I could be I would
prove me wrong all right let's watch
this foreign
[Music]
problem in this country
it's called Muslim we know our current
president is one you know he's not even
an American
[Music]
this is cut up yeah we need yeah you
show four seconds where you can barely
hear anything like this isn't what it's
gonna do
this is why people have the opinions
that they do
we're going to be looking at a lot of
different things
all right first of all the guy talking
about even if that was even if that was
accurate right didn't say getting rid of
Muslims getting rid of training camps
where we want people want to kill like
that you know it's just an assumption
and it's leaping and this the the no one
is twisting anything this video is very
clear like this is what people believe
though that an edited video oh and then
in the full video Trump said that's the
first question yeah so yeah I mean
that's that's what I don't like so again
so when I did see Trump speak in full
and of course I can't remember the shits
of years ago but I can remember seeing
the news that the trump-hating news and
going that's not what happens that's not
what happened that's not what he said
it's out of context even then so here
David Letterman is is taking things I
believe out of context again we should
look deeper I'm happy to because at this
point we're questioning everything yeah
and
I can't be on a high horse and tell
people who disagree with me to question
everything unless I'm owning that and
also questioning everything so it's a
real pain in the ass to question
everything I got to tell you question
everything do it because nothing you're
hearing is true but you know what it's a
pain in the ass I'm also going to tell
you that it takes up a lot of time but
it creates a lot of Peace because when
you know the truth you can accept it and
either choose to just you know carry on
because you're happy with the truth or
move on or go out and fight for what's
right but has that chair ever been that
Humane when biting cold Trump the first
racist president ever well clearly
that's not true so how do I feel when I
hear a white person say some stupid [ __ ]
okay I'm glad that I'm glad that he
acknowledged that that's like whatever
they're all full [ __ ] yeah exactly I
just like the thing is I just hate when
stuff is ripped up and taken out of
context on both sides like I saw
something the other day who's the
current Speaker lady the black woman
that speaks for the at the White House
oh my God but I saw a clip of her on
Twitter where they were making fun of
her acting like she didn't know what she
was talking about but the clip was like
completely chopped up and taken out of
context and then I commented I was like
I hate this you know I hate when the
left does this it's not okay when the
right does it either and then I got hit
I'm like you guys are wrong oh yeah I
know Ryan they call you a rhino and
you're all these things because you know
what Rhino is
Republican and name only yeah so you're
like the anti-republic you might as well
be a Democrat but you call yourself a
republican yeah you're right nobody
wants the [ __ ] truth it's crazy what
are you gonna do all right thank you
guys for watching make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram if you
want to learn how to go viral on social
media you can join the Discord and you
can also drop videos for us to react to
there I think you should join the
Discord anyway because there's some cool
people in there yeah there is we have a
really cool community there mom sits in
chats all day she's a Discord mod I'm no
I don't I'm getting there I'm starting
to learn how to I just figured out how
to use the Discord I'm trying I go ahead
and say hi though
I'm learning I'm gonna be a Discord
Master soon okay he doesn't believe in
me
[Music]
[Music]